a guy who entered the league three years
ago and who now can sign
a second contract lamar jackson the 2019
nfl mvp
and a guy who got the ravens back to the
playoffs this year and got a playoff win
here is john harbaugh the coach of the
ravens his end of season press
conference talking about
lamar jackson and what to expect with
the team's offense going forward
i'm very confident that that eric and
those guys will do a great job of
looking at that of course
absolutely we want you know lamar to uh
to sign a long-term deal and be with us
and that's i'm totally
certain that that's going to happen
we'll build the passing game around our
players and our talent and around our
quarterback and around our running backs
around our offensive line to suit our
players
to play winning football to score points
i mean i think we were the seventh or
eighth highest
scoring offense in the league last year
so we can talk about the other 24 23 of
those teams
and talk about what they're not doing to
fit somebody's eye but it goes back to
and the reason i'm strong on this is
because it goes back to the same
criticism that we've heard
for the last three years about not not
being the type of of an offense or the
type of a quarterback that
some people want to see and that's just
they're just going to have to live with
it because lamar jackson's won a lot of
football games here
and our offense has won us a lot of
football games here and we're not
apologizing that for one second we are
going to improve it no question about it
we're going to go to work to be more
precise more efficient
better at what we do that's what we have
to do be better at it
they do have to improve their passing
though if they want to attract
free agents to join that team and they
need a veteran presence in the receiver
room
i don't assume that dez bryant will be
back again they need someone out there
who
who says i choose the ravens and i play
receiver and i believe that the passing
game is going to flourish they really
need to have that happen and as to the
contract
of lamar jackson he doesn't have an
agent
and it's going to be interesting to see
what that contract looks like
what they negotiate directly with him i
think his mother handles his business
affairs
will they do what we've seen other teams
do when they negotiate with a guy who
doesn't have an agent
and take advantage of him russell
okung's contract with the
broncos was an abomination the richard
sherman contract with the 49ers i know
he would strongly disagree with me
also an abomination not nearly
reflective of his value
not nearly what he could have or should
have gotten are the ravens going to do
that to lamar jackson or are they going
to give him something that is closer to
market value
and it's going to be hard to do it this
year with the salary cap where it is
so i know they'd like to do it and i
presume he'd like to get his reward
sharing but i think it's going to be a
delicate thing for the ravens because
they're going to be in a position where
maybe they can take advantage of the
situation it'll be interesting to see if
they do
mike i have a question for you okay he's
played three years right and i agree
he's done a lot
in the regular season he was mvp last
year he's done a lot in the regular
season he's won a lot of games the
ravens have won
he's one and three in the postseason
would you give him a contract after this
third year based on what you've seen
especially in the postseason
no and here's why look at carson wentz
and jared goff
we've been focused with obsessed on that
over the past two months yeah once you
lock in you better be damn sure that the
guy
that you're paying is going to be the
guy that he's been
and for me i continue to have some
concerns about the injury issue although
he can
he continues to defy any in all
expectations i remember when he became
the starter
you know there were folks who said hey
it'll be it'll be fun while it lasts
but it ain't going to last very long
well it's lasted and it works
i i don't know what i would do i i don't
know if i would do a short-term
extension
i don't know if i'd pay him close to
market value right now that's 45 million
i'm not doing that
but i think i would wait one more year
and i would use the salary cap
issues as a legitimate reason and what i
would do is i would approach him and say
look if you want to do the contract now
here's what we can do we can do more
next year
assuming that both sides want to do
something next year but for this year
this is all we can do because of the cap
i'm sorry but that's just the way it is
and then i would build in some
flexibility
so i could i could cut the cord if i
wanted to unlike
the rams who would love to cut the cord
right now on jared goff and can't
shireen
exactly that was my exact thought mike
and
that's a good out and it's a legitimate
out that they would have and if you can
somehow get him to sign a shorter term
deal
for not market value then then even
better but if you don't
you have another year to see what you
have in him and and then are firmly
convinced that he's your guy you've seen
him for four years you've seen him in
the postseason
i just want to see more from lamar
jackson in the postseason to know that
he is the guy that lead me to the super
bowl because i haven't seen that yet
yeah i agree with you completely even
though he is a great quarterback he won
an mvp
you don't i mean the eagles and rams
examples
are the warning shot for the rest of the
league just because you got a guy in
round one who's turned into a great
quarterback
that doesn't mean that it's right for
you
to do a market level deal that you may
regret within a year or two the eagles i
don't know
i don't know what their feeling really
is on carson wentz because i think
there is a belief that it's just an
aberration like it was year three for
ben roethlisberger year four for peyton
manning we'll see
but it's definitely a source of regret
for the la rams and the ravens
who have managed their team impeccably
relative to other teams over the years
yeah you're going to have a periodic
mistake like an earl thomas
but i think they'll end up doing the
smart thing and the right thing for them
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports